[Music]
when i was in high school
i struggled to run the mile in gym class
i i think i made it every time but
barely
you know i ran a a competitive 15-minute
mile
sometimes 16 or 17 minutes lindsay flock
uh just competed in the heptathlon
the olympic trials that obviously
impressive enough
shocking she did it well 18 weeks
pregnant
uh so i now i i feel
that i have absolutely no way to relate
in any way
to this sort of accomplishment but there
are many aspects of this story that are
so impressive the athletic aspect
the political aspect it's just at a time
when there's so many
unpleasant stories coming out of the
news and especially out of the olympics
i was just elated and so i'm very
pleased to be joined by lindsay flock
lindsay thank you for being here
thank you for having me so is the secret
would i have done better in high school
had i been pregnant is that does that
make it makes it easier to run or
no uh i would not
say that this is a really
stunning feat i mean i'm real i just had
my first son well i didn't have my son
but my wife
just had our first son and you know at
various parts of that pregnancy you can
barely get out of bed
one feels sick you know it's kind of
hard to move around and you you did one
of the most
difficult athletic events that you can
possibly do can you just take us through
a little bit of that process
i mean presumably you did not plan your
pregnancy
to coincide with uh with the olympic
trials
congratulations on your son this is
actually my first
we did not necessarily plan
to be pregnant at the olympic trials um
with covet happening and everything last
year i
truly believed that the olympics were
not going to happen this year just
because of the postponement from last
year
um and so we just said okay we'll see
what happens
um i was actually very sick in the very
beginning so if it was probably three
weeks prior
i probably wouldn't have been at the
olympic trials um
but i actually started to feel really
good and so i was just like well i can
do this
it's something my body's used to but
it's not as though you just wake up one
day and say okay i'm going to run a
heptathlon
obviously there's some training involved
here so you know you were
sort of down for the count
during the weeks leading up to running
at the tr
i should point out by the way you beat
three people you beat three
non-pregnant women in in the heptathlon
yes i tried to do as much training as i
possibly could
leading up into the trials and then we
literally just took it day by day hour
by day hour to see what events
and i'm so glad i was able to make it
through all of them now
there is a little bit of a political
dimension here as well which is
and it seems ghastly like you you
wouldn't i guess nothing surprises
anyone these days
but there have been cases including in
the olympics where women
found out they were pregnant and but
they still wanted to compete and they
would they would get an abortion because
they would choose the olympics over
having a child and you you did not do
that
you very very courageously wouldn't do
that
but then you you didn't give up the
olympics either you kind of you somehow
or the olympic trials rather you somehow
just managed to do both
yes i knew that i could be capable of i
knew i wasn't going to be at
the potential that i was 18 weeks or
even probably 12 weeks before because i
actually did do three meets um
pretty well for myself um in my weeks
four through six
being pregnant um but that was
definitely not an option for us
so you you know i mean presumably
you're looking at 2020 2020 gets
postponed because of the lockdowns
then it's 2021 and this is the last
chance i mean
you're you're not you had already made
that decision correct
you were not going to compete the next
car round
correct so so what is that process like
you've been training at this thing i
mean look i'm not exactly the most uh
adonis of a fella here so i but
presumably you've been
training at this thing your entire life
this is a very specialized skill
for you know effectively the height of
athletic achievement
and then and then it's just over and
then you got to do something else
yes and that's what's crazy because in
january of 2020 i actually left
it was my fiance at the time we hadn't
gotten married yet but i had left him i
had left
my job i had moved three hours away and
like gave up everything to like
completely focus on the 2020 olympics
trials and then hopefully the olympics
and when it all kind of
shifted away from that um i just knew
this was my third olympic trials um
this chapter at some point needed to
come to an end which is really hard for
athletes to give up
um and so we finally just decided okay
um
let's just end one chapter and begin the
other
however that goes about and um
i don't think that part has actually hit
me because of what happened at the
trials
that's right because i love this idea we
go through
chapters in our lives you you know you
don't get to stay in high school forever
you don't get to stay in college forever
you don't get to
pursue your professional sporting event
forever you don't you don't get to
pursue your career forever you know
these things are discreet and it was so
distressing when i read a story of one
woman who
who had had an abortion just basically
to continue to compete in the olympics
i thought oh my gosh you're giving up
the most
important thing in your life which will
which will define the rest of your life
you're giving that up for this really
time limited thing
obviously competing at the olympics it's
extraordinarily impressive
but that's only going to be a few years
and then you're giving up all the rest
so how did you
how did you have the foresight i mean i
know a lot of athletes
who are just just even be in that
competitive mindset
are really only looking at the near term
and it's hard as an athlete and for us
we had just decided like that
was never going to be an option for us
we
it's hard like i mean we got into the
doctor's office at
eight weeks we heard the heartbeat it's
there's a very
defined baby there um and so we just
decided like
that that's more important because of
our life down the road
um and that's what we truly want and it
it does like
athletic career has to come to an end
mine on the track has come to an end but
i'm still gonna go out there and
train and be a healthy lifestyle so
that eight-week appointment is a pretty
big one when it happened
for us it was also during the lockdowns
and they had the audacity to
tell me that i couldn't go to any of the
appointments beforehand but then you
know you go to that
that first one really where you can kind
of hear the heartbeat
and you just realize oh my goodness and
especially when you when you then get
the ultrasound
if it's a 3d ultrasound even more so
where you think oh
this is a person even now my little son
he's always got his hands he looks like
a little irish boxer you know he looks
like gangs of new york style his hands
always up by his face
and we never got a good ultrasound
because he was always doing that in the
womb as well
and you have this stunning realization
oh yeah the
baby that's right that was the same
thing that was inside his mother
10 weeks ago 20 weeks ago yes we
actually have that one
um the anatomy scan the 3d on friday
so i'm really excited because we haven't
had one since eight weeks so
that'll be the next one so what what is
the the feeling now you've come down
from this incredible high
performing extra extraordinarily well at
the olympic trials
now that's it that's the end of that
career was there any moment was there
any moment of
kind of let down depression even to say
now that phase of my life is over or no
just right into the next thing
um right before the 800 when the cameras
that were on me i think it kind of hit
me hard before the gun went off
i did almost start to tear up then but
it was so fast into the gun that
that had finished um but ever since then
um i've just been back to work i coach
athletes
um both youth and adults and so it's
just been jumped right
into that and i think after the baby it
might hit me a little bit harder
just for the fact of like there's so
much going on right now
being still sick a little bit body
changing
exhaustion um but when i actually can
step back on the track i think it'll hit
me a little bit
harder because there was there was one
race that you you did have to step off
the track
because basically it was so hot outside
you you feared for for your health and
the health of your baby
yes so um in the 800 i only ran 100
meters of it and stepped off and that
was the last event in the head
and the reason for that is was saturday
after the 200 i actually did end up in
the medical tent because it was so hot
um
we were trying to get me rehydrated and
so we just didn't want to take that
chance especially with sunday being
so much hotter than saturday was right
right and
that's even at another level this moment
you okay you're there you're on the
field you're doing it
you're on the track rather and then but
no i can't take this risk there's
something more important here even than
how well i run
yes and i am stubborn and my husband and
coach were in the stands and they
really didn't think i would walk off the
track they
thought i would continue and finish it
so
what i feel is so inspiring about this
whole story
is obviously you're a top athlete
obviously but
that you've got all the priorities in
order and i know a lot of people these
days think you've just got a pick
you've either got to pick your personal
life or your professional life or you've
got to pick
having a family or doing well in your
career you got to pick this or you got
and that that really in my experience is
not the case these things kind of work
together and if you flourish in one area
of your life you're going to flourish
in all of the other areas and i i tell
you i look around at
professional athletes and and really
people in other fields too
and i don't i don't see that kind of a
sensible attitude
that you've demonstrated yes and i think
that's what a lot of people don't
understand is they can do
both um in any career it doesn't have to
just be athletics they can be a mom they
can be pregnant they can
still continue their career yes there
will be different changes but there's
always
obstacle there's always struggles that
everyone has to go through in life
whether you're pregnant or not
right that's true and there are some
payoffs there as well as you're going to
find out you've still got a bit of
pregnancy to go through i think but
uh so so lindsey where can people find
you unless
unless right now you say i'm done with
that no one should follow me at all i'm
going into private life
um i'm on instagram at lc schwartz22 you
can find me there i am going to continue
to share my story from here on out i've
been kind of shy
in the public eye i didn't used to like
pictures um
but all the people that women men have
that
have shared their stories with me i
truly want to keep
inspiring and i will continue to share
on that platform that's great that's
really really inspiring stuff i
still would not run against you even at
20 weeks spread
call me when you're about 37 weeks
pregnant and then i think
i may i'll say i was able to
run faster than one of the top athletes
but frankly maybe not even then
maybe not even then deal deal lindsay
great to be with you lindsey flock thank
you so much for joining us
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
[Music]
you